yes you read that title correctly i
think there's a pretty good chance that
apple's mac pro is coming this year and
then it's actually gonna pack a new quad
die chip yes that's four dies instead of
two that apple just gave us with the m1
ultra max studio and no it's not going
to look like this because this simply
isn't possible because all the memory
channels are getting blocked by the
other dies and while this is certainly a
possibility that i'm open to i don't
think it's what apple is going to be
doing because we just discovered some
brand new apple patents that reveal a
new technology that is even more
impressive and before i get into all the
leaks and rumors that are pointing to my
conclusion of the mac pro still coming
this year as well as the patents that
show how apple could achieve the new
quad chip i want to show you guys the
new patents that reveal how apple was
able to create the m1 ultra chip because
it's just straight up genius as you
probably already know the m1 ultra uses
two m1 max dies connected together
through the secret die to die
interconnect that i actually showed you
guys way back in december when someone
took a real photo of the m1 max but what
you probably don't know is that apple is
actually fusing them together while in
the wafer printing process so apple
essentially prints a bunch of m1 max
dies onto a wafer and then they run
tests to check for flaws within the dies
and if there are enough functioning
cores inside of both neighboring m1 max
dies apple moves on to the next step in
the wafer process using 2.5 d technology
to route over 10 000 signals through the
interposer connecting both m1 max dies
to create what's known as the new ultra
fusion connection with up to 2.5
terabytes per second of bandwidth and
then finally they dice up the wafer into
various m1 ultra chips as well as the m1
max dies that didn't quite pass the core
test and for the m1 max size that had
way too many flaws the bottom half would
be sliced off creating an m1 pro dye
that apple can still throw into a mac
and sell instead of having to throw it
away which is what makes this new m1
chip making process so profitable for
apple but going back to the ultra fusion
interposer if 2.5 terabytes per second
sounds like overkill i agree because the
memory bandwidth is limited to 800
gigabytes per second so the big question
is why would apple go so overboard with
ultra fusion well i think it's because
they're giving it enough overhead to
prepare for the mac pros quad die chip
so before i get into apple's patents for
the new 3d printing technology that'll
allow them to do this let me first
explain why i think this mac pro is
still coming this year despite minchi
quo saying that it's getting delayed
until
2023 when apple announced the m1 ultra
max studio apple told us that they still
have one more mac to complete the ultra
silicon transition the mac pro making
our transition nearly complete with just
one more product to go mac pro now the
important thing to realize here is that
apple mentioned the word transition
which refers back to apple announcing a
two-year transition of their mac lineup
over to apple silicon so if apple knew
that they were delaying the mac pro
until next year then saying the word
transition would be embarrassing if they
failed on that promise by not
transitioning the mac pro within the
two-year timeline and the even bigger
point is that apple said that they would
leave the announcement of the mac pro
for another day but that is for another
day which is 100 guaranteed to get some
people to hold off on buying the brand
new mac studio and wait for the mac pro
that'll have i guess a new chip we
haven't even heard about yet and
that's the one i'm gonna keep waiting
for so it would be incredibly stupid for
apple to say that they're saving the mac
pro announcement for another day but
then have people waiting over a full
year not buying the mac studio and not
buying any high-end apple products that
would be very dumb so because of that i
think apple has confirmed that it's
going to be coming soon this year and if
you needed more confirmation ross young
has finally confirmed that his leaks for
the 27-inch imac pro were actually wrong
because his team didn't expect the new
studio display to come with a webcam
speakers and a built-in a13 chip so he
now believes that his 27-inch imac pro
leaks were actually for the upcoming
studio display xdr with a mini led panel
and 120hz promotion which has already
gone into production and should be
revealed at apple's wwdc event and if he
is right then i 100 guarantee that the
new mac pro will also be revealed at the
event because it makes zero sense to
release a new display by itself there
needs to be a new mac product to go
alongside the display just like apple
just did with the studio mac but then
going further ta tech15 on twitter
confirmed that the mac studio only has
one model number regardless of the chip
that's inside of it which means that out
of the three new mac model numbers apple
registered with the eec there are still
two of them remaining which includes
another desktop mac which i believe is
the mac pro and if the mac pro does get
revealed at wwdc then it would mean that
we are in fact going to be getting
something that's even more powerful than
the m1 ultra mac studio yes a new quad
die chip however there is a pretty big
problem in terms of what the chip could
be going into this machine because we
were expecting the quad chip to be based
on the m1 because mark german said that
the mac pro will come with up to a 40
core chip with literally four m1 max
dies put together and the crazy thing is
that he was a hundred percent right with
all of his leaks about the 10 core m1
max chip as well as the 20 core m1 ultra
chip which he nailed perfectly so how
could he be wrong about the m1 quad chip
well first of all hector martin who was
a software developer working to bring
linux to apple silicon has confirmed
that the m1 max's interrupt controller
only has support for two dies which
means that a four die chip is literally
impossible if it's based on the m1 and
because of that mark german has
literally just confirmed on his twitter
space's version of power on that he
believes that apple has shifted the m1
ultra duo chip over to the m2 ultra duo
so this means that instead of a 40 core
chip we could actually see a 48 chord
ship because there are leaks from 9 to 5
max saying that the m2 pro and max chips
will actually have 12 cpu cores instead
of 10. and in his twitter spaces mark
also confirmed that he thinks that the
regular m2 chip will be announced
between may and july which makes a wwdc
release likely and then adding to all of
this we just got a couple of brand new
leaks from sources like mori qhd who
says that apple is about to release a
chip even better than the m1 ultra which
hints at an m1 or m2 ultra duo chip and
then leek's apple pro just gave us an
exclusive leak mentioning that apple is
planning on releasing the mac pro this
year with two or even four and one ultra
chips alongside this studio display but
they won't be shipping until later in
the year maybe as late as december so
with all that said let's finally get
into these brand new patents that detail
how apple can make the quad die chip
happen within some of the patents they
showed a new future die that has
interconnects on both the left and right
sides which means that they can combine
four dies side by side interconnecting
them all which would mean that all the
ram and i o connections would have to be
on the top and bottom which makes it a
bit difficult unless apple could use ram
stacking technology to stack two ram
packages on top of each other instead of
having multiple ram packages like they
do on the m1 ultra however this method
of combining dies side by side could be
problematic because the left die would
have to send data through the middle
dies all the way over to the right die
so i don't think that apple is going to
be going with this method and now the
other method which i think is much more
likely is that apple would literally
take two m2 ultra chips and stack them
on top of each other like you see in
this image and the reason that this is
the better method is because they can
not only connect over 10 000 signals
between the two m2 max dies but they can
add even more signals vertically from
the bottom m2 ultra dye up through a new
vertical ultrafusion interposer into the
second m2 ultra chip which will
interconnect all of them in the most
efficient way possible and this would
allow the bottom left eye to communicate
directly with the top right die kind of
like in an x pattern as well as to any
other die in the m2 ultra duo chip and
if you think this sounds absolutely
insane check out these detailed
screenshots from apple's patents the
second package level dies and passive
interposer chiplet may include active
side face up toward the first package
level that includes a plurality of
contact pads and dialectic layer all or
only a group of the plurality of dyes
may include a communication bridge
routing which is used to connect at
least two chips from an adjacent package
level that right there is literally the
ultra fusion interposer going vertically
to the second layer of dies moving
further a communication path can exist
between any given pair of terminals thus
the communication bridges can be
incorporated into the silicon within
each and all active dyes where each dye
can be bonded to a pair of dyes in an
opposing package level to provide the
communication path or die stitching
between the two dies but wait there's
more in this manner the dies can form a
full 3d ic interconnect fabric along all
the dies on all package levels passive
silicon interposer stitching dies can
also be included within the interconnect
fabric so this literally means stitching
four dies together through an interposer
like ultra fusion so they can all
communicate together and this is a quick
sketch of what it could look like two
ultras on top of each other and if
you're wondering how high the top die
will sit on top of the bottom die i
think it'll literally be stacked flush
on top of it micro bumps may utilize
more conventional assembly techniques
while hybrid bonding with metal to metal
and oxide dioxide bonding can achieve a
high connection density and lower
latency for higher end applications as
well as smaller z height or vertical
height so if you want to imagine how all
of this will look like this is a patent
image of the m1 ultra chip showing eight
ram chips as well as the two m1 max dies
so here is my modified version showing
how apple can easily stack another ultra
chip onto the current one and then adapt
the metal heat transfer cover for
cooling and if you're wondering how
apple could possibly cool this m2 ultra
duo chip i'll leave that for another
video but if you enjoyed seeing how
apple could make this mac pro quad chip
possible go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe because we're getting
our max studio in very soon and we're
going to tear it down so thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video